[Applause]
my mother called
this summer
to stage an intervention
uh she'd uh
come across
a few snippets of
my memoir which wasn't even out yet and
she was concerned
it wasn't the sex
it was the language
that disturbed her
for example
i have been so many things
along my curious journey
a poor boy
a
a yale man
a harvard man
a
a christian
a crack baby alleged the spawn of satan
the second coming
casey
that's just page six
so you may understand my mother's word
but she wanted only to make
one small
change so she called
and she began
hey
you are a man
you're not a
you're not a punk and let me tell you
the difference you are prominent
you are intelligent you dress well you
know how to speak people like you
you don't walk around doing your hand
like a punk
you're not a vagabond on the street
you are an upstanding person
who just happens to be gay
don't put yourself over there
when you
are over here
she thought she had done me a favor
and in a way she had
her call it clarified
what i am trying to do with my life
and in my work as a writer
which is to send
one simple message
the way we're taught to live
has got to change
i learned this the hard way
i was born not on the wrong side of the
tracks but on the wrong side of a whole
river
the trinity
down in oakland texas i was raised there
in part by my grandmother who worked as
domestic and by my sister
who adopted me a few years after our
mother who struggled with mental illness
disappeared
there was that disappearance
that began when i was 13 and lasted for
five years
that shaped the person i became
the person i later had to
unbecome
before she
left my mother had been my human hiding
place she was the only other person
who seemed as strange as me
beautifully strange some mix of blanche
dubois from a streetcar named desire and
the 1980s whitney houston
[Laughter]
i'm not saying she was perfect
just that i sure benefited from her
imperfections and maybe that's what
magic is after all
a useful mistake
so when she began to disappear for days
at a time i turned to some magic of my
own it struck me as from above
that i could conjure up my mother just
by walking perfectly
from my elementary school at the top of
a steep hill all the way down to my
grandmother's house
placing one foot and one foot only in
each sidewalk square
i couldn't let any part of any foot
touch the line between the square i
couldn't skip a square all the way to
the last square at the last blade of
grass that separated our lawn from our
driveway
and i you not
it worked
just once though
but if my perfect walk could not bring
my mother back i found that this
approach
had other uses
found that everyone else in charge
around me loved nothing more than
perfection
obedience
submission
or at least if i submit it they wouldn't
bother me too much so i took a bargain
that i'd later see in a prison a stasi
prison in berlin
on a sign that read he who adapts can
live tolerably
it was a bargain that helped ensure i
had a place to stay and food to eat
a bargain that warned me praise of
teachers and ken strangers a bargain
that paid off big time it seemed when
one day at 17 a man from yale showed up
at my high school to recruit me for
yale's football team
felt as out of the blue to me then as it
made you now
the yale man said
everybody said
that this was the best thing that could
ever happen to me
best thing that could happen to the
whole community take this ticket boy
they told me
i was not so sure
yale seemed another world entire a cold
foreign
hostile place
on the first day of my recruiting visit
i texted my sister an excuse for not
going these people are so weird
she replied
you'll fit right in
i took the ticket
and worked damn hard to fit right in
when my freshman advisor warned me not
to wear my fitted hats on campus you're
at yale now you don't have to do that
anymore she said
i figured this was just one of the small
prices that must be paid to make it
i paid them all
or try it and sure enough they seem to
pay me back
made me a leader on the varsity football
team
got me into a not so secret society and
a job on wall street and later in
washington things were going so well
that i figured naturally i should be
president of the united states
but since i was only 24
and since even presidents have to start
somewhere i settled instead on a run for
congress
now this was in the afterglow of that
great 2008 election
election during which a serious
moderate senator stressed
the message you've got to send
more than any other message is that
barack obama is just like us
they sent that message so well
that their campaign became the gold
standard of modern politics if not
modern life which also seems to demand
that we each do whatever it takes
to be able to say at the end of our days
with peace and satisfaction i was just
like everybody else
this would be
my message too
so one night i made one final call to my
prospective campaign manager
we do the
things it take to win but first he had
one question
is there anything i need to know
i held the phone
and finally said well
you should probably know i'm gay
silence
hmm
i see
he nearly whispered as if he found a
shiny penny or a dead baby bird
i'm glad you told me he continued he
definitely didn't make my job any easier
i mean you are in texas
but it's not impossible
not impossible
but casey let me ask you something
how are you gonna feel
when somebody say at a rally
calls you a
and let's be real okay
you do understand that somebody might
want to physically harm you
i just want to know
are you really ready for this
i wasn't
and i could not
understand you could hardly
breathe
or think
or say a word
but to be clear the boy that i was at
that time would have leapt at the chance
to be harmed to sacrifice everything
even life for a cause
there was something shocking though
not that there should have been but
there was
and the notion that he might be harmed
for nothing more than being himself
which he had not even tried to do in the
first place
all that he
all that i
had tried to do and be was what i
thought was asked of me
i was prominent
for a 24 year old
intelligent
i spoke well dressed decent i was an
upstanding citizen
but the bargain i'd accepted
could not save me
after all
nor can it save you
you may have already learned this lesson
or you will
regardless of your sexuality
the queer receives a concentrated dose
no doubt but repression is a bitter pill
that's offered to us all
we're taught to hide so many parts of
who we are and what we've been through
our love our pain
for some our faith
so while coming out to the world can be
hard
coming into all the raw strange magic of
ourselves can be much harder
as david said it takes a long time to
sound like yourself
that surely was the case for me
i had my private revelation that night
at 24 but mostly went on with my life
went on harvard business school started
a successful non-profit wound up on the
cover of a magazine on the stage at ted
i had achieved by my late twenties about
everything the kid is supposed to
achieve
but i was real cracked up
not exactly having a nervous breakdown
but not too far off
an awful sad either way
i never thought of being a writer
didn't even read in earnest until i was
nearly 23.
but the book business is about the only
industry that will pay you to
investigate your own problems so
[Laughter]
so i decided to give it a try
to trace those cracks
with words
now what came out on the page was about
as strange as i felt at that time which
alarmed some people at first a respected
writer called to stage his own
intervention after reading a few early
chapters
and he began much like my mother
hey
listen
you've been hired to write an
autobiography it's a straightforward
exercise it's got a beginning middle and
end and it's grounded in the facts of
your life
and by the way there's a great tradition
of autobiography in this country led by
people on the margins of society who
write to assert their existence go buy
some of those books
and learn from them
you're going in the wrong direction
but i no longer believed what we are
taught
that the right direction is the safe
direction i no longer believed what we
are taught that queer lives or black
lives our poor lives our marginal lives
i believe what kendrick lamar says on
section 80.
i'm not on the outside looking in
i'm not on the inside looking out i'm in
the dead center looking around
that was the place
from which i hoped to work headed in the
only direction worth going the direction
of myself trying to help us all refuse
the awful bargains we've been taught to
take
we're taught to turn ourselves and our
work into little nuggets that are easily
digestible
taught to mutilate ourselves so that we
make sense to others
to be a stranger to ourselves so the
right people might befriend us and the
right schools might accept us and the
right jobs might hire us and the right
parties might invite us and someday the
right god might invite us to the right
heaven and close his pearly gates behind
us so we can bow down to him forever and
ever these are the rewards they say
for our obedience
to be a well-liked holy nugget
to be dead
and i say
in return
no thank you
to the world
and to my mother
well to tell you the truth all i said
was okay mom i'll talk to you later but
but in my mind i said no thank you
i cannot accept
her bargain either
nor should you it will be easy
for many of us in rooms like this
to see ourselves as safe
to keep ourselves
over here
we speak well
we dress decent
we're intelligent
people like us
or act like they do
but instead
i say that we should remember lot's wife
jesus of nazareth said it first to his
disciples remember
lot's
wife
lot
in case you haven't read the bible
recently
was a man who set his family down in
sodom in the midst of a wicked society
that god decided he had to destroy
but god being cruel yet still a sap in
part rushed two angels out to sodom to
warn lot to gather up his folks and get
out of dodge
lot hurt the angels warning but delayed
they didn't have all day to wait so they
grabbed lot's hands and his two
daughters hands and his wife's hands and
hurried them out of sodom and angel
shout
escape to the mountain
whatever you do don't look back just as
god starts raining down fire on sodom
and gomorrah i can't figure out how
gamora got dragged into this but
lot and his folks are running
fleeing all that destruction kicking up
dust while the lord rains down death and
then
for some reason
lot's wife looks
back
god turns her into a pillar of salt
remember
lot's wife
jesus says
but i've got a question
why did she look back
did she look back because she didn't
want to miss the mayhem
wanted one last glimpse of a city on
fire
did she look back because she wanted to
be sure that her people were far enough
from danger to breathe a little easy
i'm so nosy and selfish sometimes those
likely would have been my reasons if i'd
been in her shoes
but what if something else was going on
with this woman
lot's wife
what if she could not bear the thought
of leaving those people
all alone to burn alive even for
righteousness sake
isn't that possible
if it is
then this backward glance of a
disobedient woman may not be a
cautionary tale after all it may be the
bravest act in all the bible
even braver than the act that holds the
whole book together crucifixion
we are told
that up on calvary
on an old rugged cross
jesus gave his life to save everybody
billions and billions of strangers for
all time to come
it's a nice thing to do
made him famous that's for sure
but lot's wife was killed
turned into a pillar of salt
all because she could not turn her back
on her friends
the wicked men of sodom
and nobody even wrote the woman's name
down
oh to have the courage
of lot's wife
that's the kind of courage
we need today
the courage to put ourselves over there
the courage that says that either all of
us have to be or none of us can
be for any of us to be free
the courage to stand
with other vagabonds in the street with
all the wretched of the earth
to form an army of the least of these
with the faith
that from the naked crust of all we are
we can build
a better world
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]